[Música]
o sol se bonita mais um vídeo e hoje vou
ensinar como fazer uma coluna utilizando
uma laranja para começar quanto uma
laranja mãe como um cuidado porém
crianças peçam ajuda do disque recorta
estas ligações que a casca usando uma
miniatura e depois como a colher querem
tudo com muito cuidado para deixar a
casca banheiro system por muito tempo
outra sacola pva e vou pintar de ambos
os lados da casca
se vocês quiserem podem passar mais do
que uma camada agora usar um fio de
cobre esmaltado ou seja é um fio tem uma
proteção à volta e vocês não quiserem
comprar podem ser por ter ares do motor
avariado e vocês com quem lá mais ou
menos 10 metros de fio a volta down
cilíndrico que tenham dentro geralmente
maior o imã que vocês vão utilizar e que
mais para frente
[Música]
aprendeu utilizando fita cola desta
maneira para eu não ter lá de bom
agora vou mostrar como fazer a parte que
vibra de acumular para isso utilizará
inicialmente uma folha de papel e um com
base passa um círculo que seja maior do
diâmetro da laranja
depois uns alojamento mais que nunca
dentro da laranja e depois um pequeno
círculo que fica lá no maio para dar uma
forma de prato vocês a encurtar estas
linhas a volta depois do brasil desta
forma irregular o dinâmico uma cola tva
com tampa cobra qualquer que você
estiver lá trincado
o prato vai ficar um pouco grande então
para deixar o céu com o tamanho certo
você tem que colocar a laranja por cima
fazer uma linha a volta do contorno e
depois de cortar usando uma tesoura
[Aplausos]
quando deixarem o tamanho certo vocês
têm colar a bovina no meio do círculo
comprado usando coloquei um tempo outra
cola e qualquer porque coluna vibra mais
utilizar uma esponja daquelas que nós
vamos na homem para lavar a louça e vou
cortar um circo vai enfim colocar uma
gota de cola no mais gasolina depois
ponha uma esponja por cima é tão outras
gotas de cola em cima da esponja e
coloque um super imã que como eu disse
no início o imã ser ligeiramente mais
pequeno eo dentro de bobinas com fios de
cobre temos malta volta como eles no
início do vídeo então é muito importante
que vocês retirem isso antes de conectar
esses carros porque não quiserem sorriso
não vai funcionar e podem também queimar
o filme do outro lado ou seja desde que
saem do tecpar nos encaixarmos dentro
dos aparelhos que usam música
para simbolizar é só vocês não darem os
carros muito bem e depois da forma que
vocês precisarem podem usar uma garrafa
de álcool uma laranja e vai ficar assim
como formais carbondale consoles e assim
espero que vocês tenham gostado estarão
mesmo deixa um gosto e isso não importa
se vai até a próxima final